play d7  okay just show me looking this way  little d7 king f7  why not king here by the way yeah  probably  g5 and that's also easy so tf7 just  trying to  correct the pawn with the king and now  some  pun ending okay f4 yeah  g5 played  taking the ice  will be difficult so you can go kf5 of  course to in a tempo who cares about  that  is that so that's completely ah  look at that it's very beautiful  well very beautiful i wouldn't say but  it's very it's a classic classic classic  you should know  and you know these classics all right  guys  thank you we are back in business  okay let's see backhoe still playing  four against three needs a door  that's redo for the frenchman and what a  result  for 18 back already quarter finals